I’m a middle child,
and I was born leaning in.
For as long as I can remember,
I've had this insatiable desire
to compete, to accomplish
and to prove myself.
My energy isn’t easily contained,
and I've been called
by both men and women
intense, high-octane,
aggressive.
These words don't feel
like compliments to me.
I try to control my eagerness.
I try to be softer.
It's exhausting.
(Laughter)
The truth is, this tough shell
conceals sensitivities and insecurities
that only those closest to me know.
And yeah, my masculine traits
make me the kind of gal
that can hang with the guys,
as long as I'm not their boss.
Last winter, I was walking
through a ski resort
and a man came up to me and said,
"Excuse me, are you
with a husband or a fiancée?"
"No," I said, and I continued
toward the lifts.
And then curiosity got the better of me.
And I turned around and asked the guy
why he wanted to know if I was with a man.
"I'm selling timeshares.
It's a real estate thing."
(Laughter)
"And you don't sell to women?"
"Oh, are you interested?"
"No."
(Laughter)
"But you do know
women carry checkbooks, too?"
And at that, he looked at me and said,
"Wow, lady, you're tough."
(Laughter)
Modern day sexism
is different than it was in the past
when a blatant comment
about a woman's physique
or a chummy pat on the derriere
was tolerated, maybe even accepted.
Today's sexism can be more subtle.
Little nuances that might seem
like no big deal to some,
but their impact can have
the effect of a thousand cuts.
That day at the ski resort resulted
in more than just another microabrasion.
It sparked a curiosity in me
about perceptions that we have
for women versus men.
I wanted to know why do we perceive women
differently when we assert ourselves.
So I did a little research
and I came across something,
just to make sure
this wasn't all on my mind,
called the competence/likability dilemma,
where women, unlike men,
are rarely perceived
to be both competent and likable.
Now we should take a moment
to define the word "likable."
Merriam-Webster says "likeable" is:
"having qualities that bring about
a favorable regard,
pleasant or agreeable."
The Urban Dictionary says:
"likeable, an adjective meaning
pleasant or attractive.
It describes something
that is easy to like."
The sad truth is, most of us don't find
strong, competent women easy to like.
In 2003, Professor Flynn
at Columbia Business School
conducted an experiment.
He took a case study about Heidi Roizen,
a successful female venture capitalist,
and he changed the name to Howard Roizen.
Everything else about
the case study remained the same.
He gave half of his class
the Heidi Roizen case study
and the other half
the Howard Roizen case study.
And he asked the students to rate
how competent and how likable
Heidi and Howard were.
Both female and male students found Heidi
and Howard to be equally competent.
But the students tended not to like Heidi.
They thought that she was a little
too aggressive and out for herself.
Neither female nor male students
wanted to work for or hire Heidi,
but they all thought Howard
would make a great colleague.
Why?
Because in our society,
women are penalized
when we behave in ways
that violate gender norms.
Our gender stereotypes show
that women should be kind, nurturing,
helpful, supportive, deferential,
while traditionally men
are expected to be decisive, competent,
assertive and strong.
So the dilemma for women
is that the qualities
which we value in leadership,
such as assertiveness and decisiveness,
go against societal norms
of what it is to be a likable woman.
I'm a documentary filmmaker,
so I'm nothing if not curious.
But I've learned that being inquisitive
is not an admired female trait.
I was at a cocktail party last week,
and I asked a man
what line of business he was in.
“Fintech,” he said.
Curious. I dug a little deeper.
"Oh, what type?"
"It's complicated."
(Laughter)
End of discussion.
OK. Now it's possible that he wanted
to spare me some long explanation,
but it's more likely that his bias,
implicit or not,
informed him that as a woman
I wouldn't understand finance.
Either way, I'm fairly certain
he wouldn't have said "it's complicated"
had I been a man.
I absorb the sting of one more cut.
Most of us are not aware of why
we don't find strong women likable.
There's just something
about her that bugs us.
But deep inside, at the root of this
is an unconscious bias.
Bias is a survival heuristic
that we inherited from our ancestors.
The problem is, it's unconscious.
And as humans, we don't have the ability
to recognize when we're being biased,
even if we can see it in other people.
We all, most of us, anyway,
believe ourselves to be fair,
open-minded and unbiased.
And yet, I will admit,
I too found Hillary's voice to be shrill.
As long as society continues to associate
leadership with masculine traits,
female leaders
will be judged more harshly,
even when they outperform
male counterparts.
So it's no wonder
that in the United States,
female politicians suffer greatly,
as our elections tend to value
likability over competency.
Women hold only
25 percent of the seats in Congress.
The competence/likability dilemma
has huge consequences,
not just in politics,
but also in education
and in the workplace,
where studies show that women
in meetings with both genders
are less likely to contribute knowledge.
As women we're told to lean in,
and yet there's backlash when we do.
A recent study shows that women
are not as good as men
at negotiating for themselves.
And yet, women outperform men
when they negotiate
on behalf of someone else.
This is because women
who negotiate for themselves
are perceived as selfish,
and women who negotiate
on behalf of someone else
are perceived to be helpful.
And a helpful woman might be liked more
than a woman who is assertive,
but the helpful woman
will not be recognized
as having what it takes
to be a successful leader.
Last week I was quoting my speaker fee
to a potential client,
and when I told him the price,
he said to me,
"Wow. Good for you. That's a lot.
Isn't documentary filmmaking
kind of, like, your hobby?"
(Laughter)
Ouch.
As humans, we're limited
to what we can do to mitigate our biases.
So even if we were able to,
say, implement a tool
that would bring more women
into upper management,
it's highly likely that we would still
evaluate the performance of those women
with biased perceptions.
Clearly, leadership and likability
should not be mutually exclusive
for women or for men.
So how do we solve for this dilemma?
I wish I could offer you
a cure to unconscious bias.
I don't believe there is one.
But we need to disrupt stereotypes
and redefine what it is
to be a leader and a woman.
Obviously, this is a long-term solution
that could take generations,
but it's a vital step.
We need to speak up.
Speak up when you witness gender bias.
Question comments that are made
about a woman's appearance or personality
rather than her skills or ability.
And we need to slow down.
Question yourself.
Reconsider your snap judgments.
Ask yourself, does that woman bug me
for reasons that really matter?
And forget about likability,
ladies, women, if you can.
Instead focus on being awesome.
Be a smart, compassionate,
effective leader
that will redefine the stereotype
of what a female leader is.
I've wasted a lot of time
worrying about how I am perceived.
If I ask a lot of questions,
will you find me combative?
If I tell you about
an accomplishment I'm proud of,
you might think I'm conceited.
But I need and seek
the approval and recognition
of my family, of my friends
and of my colleagues.
Like many of you, I want to be liked,
and I'm hopeful for the day
when women can be recognized
as being competent and likable,
a day when we value each other
regardless of gender,
for the unique contributions
that we each bring to the table.
That would be the day that
I won't have to worry about being liked.
I can just be me.
Thank you.
(Applause)